au téléphone comment hacker mieux vaut
voir venir la rondelle et savoir qui
appelle dans les dernières années le
CRTC a demandé aux fournisseur de
téléphonie mobile de mieux protéger
leurs abonnés contre les appels fraudes
en adoptant une norme commune qui permet
de vous alerter si le nom de l'appelant
et le numéro affiché ne sont pas
réellement reliés un avertissement
semblable à celui-ci vous informe que
c'est peut-être quelqu'un qui veut se
faire passer pour votre banque pour
votre compagnie d'assurance alors
bloquez ce numéro
depuis 2019 les fournisseurs doivent
aussi bloquer les appels au numéro non
conformes comme ceux qui ont trop de
chiffres qui sont bizarres ou dont
l'indicatif régional n'existe pas ce qui
fait qu'il y a moins d'appels frauduleux
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quelques années
mais il y en a encore beaucoup parce que
les fraudeurs sont vite sur leur patins
ils réussissent maintenant à afficher
des numéros de téléphone qui ont les
mêmes six premiers chiffres que votre
propre numéro ce qui leur donne une
apparence plus familière et donc plus
crédible dans le but de déjouer votre
vigilance restez alerte contre les
appels frauduleux la partie est loin
d'être gagnée facilement
[Musique]